Rodger: My name's Rodger Cornell.
I'm an explosives engineer.
Will Ferrell: Oh my god,
how do they walk away
in movies without flinching
when it explodes behind them?
There's no way!
Rodger: Okay so as soon
as this clip starts
there are a couple of
really pressing issues
that you should be focusing on.
The first is if you have grenades
and other weapons, you
shouldn't be carrying them
around inside a guitar case.
On top of that, as soon as
he pulls the grenades out
you'll notice that he pulls out not one
but two of those pins with his teeth.
I've tried it a few
times, and you really have
to put all of your strength
to get that thing dislodged.
So pulling any kind of grenade
pin out with your mouth
unless it's been tampered with beforehand
is just completely unrealistic.
Antonio Banderas: Jesus Christ.
Rodger: The most common
misconceptions I'm aware of.
One is that any explosive device
when it goes off will throw a human being
into the air. The detonation itself
and the pressure wave,
they're gonna do plenty
of damage to the human body.
Propelling you into the air isn't gonna
be one of the things that you experience.
So being thrown is not really a thing.
You also see that just
from those two grenades,
you have this gigantic fireball.
Grenades, especially a
military grenade, is gonna
be composed of what's
called secondary explosives
and these secondary explosives go
through detonation processes.
A detonation process is extremely rapid
and it's certainly not gonna
be this prolonged explosion
that you see here.
When you see a gigantic fireball
and you see just flames everywhere
and you can usually assume
that they're exaggerating quite a bit.
I mean it's not that surprising.
It's a Quentin Tarantino movie,
so I really wouldn't expect anything less.
The only explosive device that you see
in that clip is what seems
to be one pack of dynamite.
Dynamite's used specifically
for blasting operations
so even though it's made
for situations like this
if you have just one bundle in the corner
of a house, you will never
get any kind of an explosion
on this order, you might have
a chunk of the house missing
right where that explosive charge was
but that's about it,
the house would probably
still be standing, unless there were a lot
of other charges placed about the house
that we're unaware of.
Certainly not every piece
of the building would be in flames.
Samuel Jackson: Son of a--
It looks like he's in a dummy town.
Once he hears sirens, he realizes
that he's about to be in the
middle of a nuclear test.
Harrison Ford: That can't be good.
Rodger: The refrigerator's lead lined
and the reason this is important is
that the lead can actually
block certain types
of radiation. So that's the premise
is that all the lead
in this fridge is gonna
block the radiation and
somehow protect Indiana Jones.
Some of the things that are
depicting are somewhat accurate.
I mean, a nuclear detonation
or a nuclear event
would produce all kinds of light.
And it's amazingly destructive.
So they're showing the
force of it correctly
just not how it's gonna impact the fridge
which is the main issue with the scene.
Sure, the lead lining is
gonna protect a little bit
from some of the radiation,
although it's not nearly enough
to prevent all of the radiation
from affecting you, there's
no way you can survive
an impact like that.
The fact that he gets out immediately
and he'll actually walk up to look
at the aftermath of the mushroom cloud
from the nuclear event, there's
a ton of nuclear fallout
when you have these events, and you want
to be as far away from this as possible
because the radiation that it produces
it sticks around for quite a while.
And the fact that he lives on in the movie
and doesn't die in a couple hours
from radiation sickness is
just completely ridiculous.
Right off the bat
it's Michael Bay, it's
a Transformers movie
you have Deceptacons running around.
So how real can you expect it to be?
When you see the fighter jets in action
you'll notice these bursts of
light coming off the bottom.
If I had to guess what that was,
that would probably be flares.
And a lot of times
they're used so the planes
can avoid heat seeking missiles.
They're a source of heat
that can distract the missile
from continuing to fly towards the jet.
Now whether or not the Deceptacons
use heat-seeking missiles I have no idea.
Traffic Controller: Q1 snipe 090.
You are approved to drop
your 2000-class JDAMs.
Rodger: So during this initial explosion,
what I'm assuming they're
doing is essentially
marking their target.
If you're gonna drop ammunition
that don't have any kind of propulsion
or guidance, you want
to be very, very sure
where you're gonna drop those bombs.
You see Shia LaBeouf get
just almost catapulted
into the air, it almost
actually looks like he's
stepping on like a trampoline.
I can't see any reason why he would
be tumbling in the air like that.
The pressure wave that's radiating
is moving outward, away from the explosion
so if you were to be thrown at all
you might be thrown backwards
and fall to the ground
but setting that all aside,
there's at least realistic situations.
Some of the things that the aircraft did
that progression from marking your target
and then dropping the
energetic load on top of it
my guess is that he was probably consulted
as to how the Department
of Defense would actually
go through their procedures.
He takes essentially his claws
and he strikes them against the rocks
to create a spark to initiate the flame.
If I'm remembering
correctly, it's Adamantium
what his claws are made of,
which is completely fictitious.
I have no ideas what the properties of
that material would be, but
there are a lot of metals
out there that don't spark.
There are other ways to initiate fuel.
That seems like a pretty silly one
that probably wouldn't work out.
That's a very rocky surface.
Even if you got it to start burning
it would probably die out
before it ever reached the helicopter.
I would never expect this to explode.
You have a helicopter that's crashed
and that's already leaking fuel.
So when the fuel tank ruptures
there's no pressure
vessel that can heat up
that can allow pressure to build
where you'd actually get
some sort of an explosion.
But if you had an explosion on that scale
you'd have pieces of that
helicopter being thrown
in every direction, not to
mention the pressure wave
that's produced, so he would definitely
hit the ground at some point.
He regenerates, so I guess
you could walk away from this.
He'd be fine.
You see some grenade
being launched at Hancock.
And he somehow deflects it into a car.
If we just accept the
fact that he can't be hurt
and that he can just deflect bullets
and that's fine, there's
still really big issues
with this scene. The effect of the grenade
is unrealistic, the way
it initiates is incorrect
using the police car as a way
of stopping bullets is just ill advised.
Cars don't stop bullets.
Cars can deflect bullets.
Cars have a lot of weak points,
so you wouldn't want to
ever use it as a shield.
I would expect the doors to
have bullet-proof inserts
but that's about it.
The roof of the car and
the floor of the car
are probably pretty thin, those are gonna
be the most vulnerable
parts of that vehicle.
The way he's holding it is
probably the least safe way
that he could be using
that car for protection.
Will Smith: Good job!
To create an explosion that massive
you would need more explosive material
than you could carry with you
and you would need to plant it everywhere.
It would take just unlimited
financial resources
a huge amount of time to place the charges
where you need to put them.
They try to add in some
cool sound effects.
It's not gonna sound anything like that.
The actual audio event is very rapid
very loud, and it's more of a crack.
They try to show the shock
actually moving outward
essentially past Denzel,
you can see the grass
start to move forward,
and then retract back.
There, you see that little.
That was a shock wave moving past,
so seeing that sort of
motion within the grass
in that scene could actually be realistic.
If you're that close where
you can see the shock
around you, it's gonna at least hurt
because you have this
sudden change in pressure.
It's gonna feel like
someone's at the very least
just punching you as hard as they can.
You're not just gonna keep walking.
All sorts of metal being thrown.
There's fragmentation everywhere.
This is one of my favorite movies
so I really hate
laying into it like I'm about to.
So he essentially rigged this hospital
with explosives, he's
setting them off wirelessly
and then he's just watching
as the demolition unfolds.
You could have explosions
going off at different times
and different locations
so that's actually not unreasonable.
What is unreasonable is
to pull that off would
be expensive, and you'd
also need to somehow
go through a hospital and
place all these charges
without anybody noticing,
I'm not entirely sure
that he would have the resources
the time, and be able
to disguise everything
to actually pull something like this off.
Especially given what the Joker's wearing.
Heath Ledger: Hi.
There's no way he would go
through this entire process
without being seen by somebody.
Jonah Hill: It's gonna explode!
Channing Tatum: Oh my
god, roll up the windows!
Jonah: What the f*** is that?
Channing: Roll it up!
Channing: I don't care just do it!
- The funny thing is, this scene is one
of the most realistic scenes
we're probably gonna see.
There is one resounding
issue with this scene though.
All those pressurized tanks, the fact
that all these things are ruptured
and just sitting there.
Jonah: What happened?
Channing: I don't know.
It just didn't explode.
Jonah: That's weird.
That would never happen.
Jonah: I really thought
that one was gonna explode.
This I think is actually
the most accurate scene
so you have a fuel tank
that was just riddled
with bullet holes, so it has no way
of accelerating the reaction.
Channing: That's what exploded?
I don't know why chickens would explode.
Their fecal matter could probably combust
the wooden cages could light on fire
but why you'd get an
explosion, I have no idea.
I think the scene's kind of intending
to be a bit ridiculous,
and it definitely is.
Will: What accounting firm is
closed at 11 AM on a Tuesday?
Mark Wahlberg: Oh this is a s***hole.
The flame's unrealistic, but
the way they're pushed back
is actually somewhat believable.
So the fact that they aren't cut up
and that they're not bleeding profusely.
The fragmentation in that situation
would be much more deadly.
Will: I can't hear!
I can't hear!
The way he's complaining is unrealistic
but the fact that he's complaining
about his ears is actually realistic.
When you have blast over pressure
there are certain parts of the human body
that are susceptible, are very susceptible
to shifts in pressure.
Your ear drums are one,
and your lungs are another.
In extreme cases, if the
pressure was strong enough
you could rupture your
lungs, and if that happens
or if anything near that happens
he's not gonna be talking.
He's just gonna be laying there gasping
for whatever breath he can pull in
so he seems to be in much better shape
than I would imagine him to be.
If you got hit with a pressure wave
you'd probably be concussed as well.
Will: I need an MRI!
So an MRI might not be a bad idea.